so 60% of pork is consumed in Asia oh
wow and also it's yeah right
and also Asia's the fastest-growing
population in the world a lot of people
coming out of poverty and consuming more
of a Western diet which means more meat
there is no meat that we consume in
quantity has it had more research done
on it than pigs and that's because pigs
cells behave kinda like human cells Indy
bio funded us mid-july took a biopsy
that week two months later we had
prototype sausages right as that means
we can go to market much faster than
anything else so took that fat from the
from the pig and then essentially just
bring that back and there are stem cells
in there yeah so you take those stem
cells and you start to multiply them
cells undergo mitosis right so they just
like divide and these will divide again
this is why it again so we keep doubling
so the population just just goes like
this it's exponential right so then the
muscle we had separate pork muscle and
pork fat and then we put them together
and then we make a sausage activation
well the so the stem cells are what you
proliferate yes so when we have this
like exponential curve these are all
stem cells yes stem cells and then we
have like a giant giant massive stem
cells yes and then we divide them and
then we induce this one to muscle and
this one to fat
so in a very short time we'll have that
will have an entirely fetal bovine serum
free formulation it's kind of put in
context the first time I tried our
culture meet it was the week before the
tasting and we had bought some pork of
the store and grounded up interested so
that we could kind of compare it to what
we were making right we wanted to make
sure that we were making the same thing
just I was lying so we had this busy
kitchen right the way the containers of
our meat and then the the cell culture
meat and then also the the stuff from
the store and the chef was cooking stuff
up and and so he handed me something and
I ate it and like okay it's bacon I
recognized that so
can I try it stuff we made I said that
is the stuff you made so oh I was like
well that's just bacon right so it's not
that it tasted like bacon it was bacon
what are the new and interesting taste
that you that would be amazing so right
now we're actually speaking with chefs
food scientist molecular gastronomist
to say like what's what's actually
difficult for you to do in a kitchen for
instance and then can we go and actually
do that to ourselves and then you don't
have to in the kitchen you know it's
actually it comes out that way
tasting a certain way we will be using
99% less land will be using 90
six percent less water 95 percent less
greenhouse gases we can make meat that's
tastier healthier and more sustainable
[Music]
what's up everyone we are back at Indy
bio demo day we are with Bryan Spears of
New Age meets what's of it hey hey done
thanks for coming out of the show
thanks very much yes great to be here
congratulations on your epic pitch for
New Age meets on the epic company that
you are building and let's talk about
this for an even prior to the actual
company I want to know you how the hell
did you come into wanting to get into
sustainable sources of sure food
generation how much time do you have we
have time it's fine so for me I mean my
background is a chemical engineering and
then twelve years of industry experience
and research and industrial automation
so I worked for a company called
National Instruments in Austin Texas for
four years and there I did application
engineering and then product marketing
and then myself another guy start a
company called sixclear and this company
we ran for eight years and we had
customers like NASA and Sandia National
Labs GE and Cisco Systems and and what
were you building for that right what
was a building for them so in those
cases we would we kind of have the deep
research customers like NASA and
University of Texas and some Canadian
national labs for instance and in those
cases we would go into their research
labs and work with some really brilliant
scientists and we would say like hey
this is how you make a research faster
right so you will put a bunch of data
test points here here here here this is
how you organize the data this is how
you make data based decisions right how
the data can inform you on what you did
but then also what the next experiment
should be right so that will be on the
deep research side and then on the
product side with customers like Cisco
and GE that's where we would do that
same thing on the research side but then
also we will work with the or the design
and test engineers your scientist and in
that way
what you want to do is you may want to
make a prototype that you can not follow
this old throw over the wall mentality
right so there's this this old paradigm
of the Rd and the test engineer designed
a prototype and throw it over the wall
to the existing go to the automation the
production engineer right and the
production engineer will go and make a
million of these but the problem is is
if it's sourced wrong they throw it back
over the wall and they fix it they throw
it back over the wall this is really
expensive a time consuming right so my
whole career has been dropping dropping
that barrier between the two exactly
yeah so you're asking about how I got in
the movement I thought it was amazing as
exciting so for me what was your moment
yeah and to transition from that yeah so
it was it was really a matter of what I
wanted to you know do with my life this
was like the the mid 30 my mid 30s on 40
now and I you look so good it's
flattering cameras rolling I know but
you know they know they know [ __ ] they
know my kind yeah my tendencies yeah
it's just your aunt Sanford's this huh
how did how is that a damn man you're
right good good stop okay so okay so the
mid 30s and it's about question of like
okay is this my life's work this is what
I want to do so I've always been very
social impact driven I had started other
nonprofits on the side and always been
involved with him but they I found that
they got the the dregs of my time and
energy
all right so whereas my business got all
my time energy so for me it was like
okay why doesn't the the business why
why isn't the business the vehicle for
how I see the world like my strong
strong conviction not to say we did bad
things it was just a matter of we were
working with technology we had great
customers but we didn't have like the
vision of how we want to change the
world for the better
right so for that respect in that
respect I say like hey I need to go find
what this is for me so I sold out my
ownership to my former co-founder we're
still in great terms he's still running
it it's a great it's a great company
still so I kind of embarked on actually
been on sabbatical for two years I would
you do where'd you go so I moved to
Denver I was in Austin there's an Austin
Texas I moved to Denver spent a lot of
time in the mountains a lot of time like
solo hiking and camping then I did some
backpacking through Europe and Asia by
myself just thinking trying to find
where where this three-way collision is
of what I'm really passionate about what
I'm really good about what good at
and then what the world needs or what's
what's the market for my skills right so
I looked a lot of things and the more I
came back to or the might found out
about clean meat or sell based meat or
lab-grown meat cultured meat what
everyone call it the more are just
really excited like it's really cool
people eat three times a day across the
world I mean it's just yeah it's an
excellent observation yes see my travels
I've noted the same yeah so you were
like I can get to almost every plate of
food or as many planes of food as
possible
sure and that would be huge and
sustainable yeah exactly cool
okay so then what what was the how did
you land on pork you know how does how
does that happen because nobody in the
market I think was doing it and tell you
at that time though ya know so the I
mean one you could say well it's it's
pretty compelling because it's the most
consumed animal in the world right so
more than chicken more than chicken yep
so we look a million chickens per hour
died in the u.s. that's that's true but
in the world is big asian so 60% of pork
is consumed in asia oh wow and also it's
yeah right
and also Asia's the fastest-growing
population in the world a lot of people
coming out of poverty and consumed in
more of a Western diet which means more
meat right also like that that's
compelling enough but then also the fact
that there is no meat that we consume in
quantity has it had more research done
on it then pigs and that's because pigs
cells behave kinda like human cells
right so if you think about like what
have we done a lot of research on well
humans and mice and rats and dogs and
chimps but we don't eat any of those but
the overlap is there in pigs
mm-hm so that means that we can we can
not have to do or we're not to spend
time doing fundamental science again we
have like a lot of published research on
the protocols on the mediate the cell
lines and such and that's kind of
evidenced by the fact that as I saw him
ascend the pitch Indy bio funded us
mid-july took a biopsy that week two
months later we had prototype sausage
right as that means we can go to market
much faster than anything else okay tell
us about the cell biopsy what part of
the pig are you taking and then how do
you make those cells replicate sure yeah
yeah so if it's right there right across
the rib right across the rib like this
okay
okay so we had some
that there so took that fat from the
from the pig and then essentially just
bring that back and there are stem cells
in there yeah so you take those stem
cells and you start to multiply them and
so one of the slides there I show what
were these them get when you feed it
together to multiply
it's called sell clothes from media
which is basically a nutrient broth
right so it's like amino acids and
minerals and things like that and
they're also we call growth factors both
factors are proteins that will make the
cell grow right the growth factors so we
make those from our from our glands
right so like in our body or from the
animal's body they'll make those so if
we're taking them out of a body taking
cells out of a body they don't like that
they want to die right so you need to
keep them alive yes and so you need to
give them things that kind of replicate
what the environment was in the animal's
body and then from the how does it how
does it how does it grow to become a
pork sausage mm-hmm what do you do to
make it a pork sausage sure yeah so
there's two stages so there's the
proliferation stage and then the
induction or differentiation stage so in
the proliferation that's where we take
in those stem cells and you're
multiplying them so part of my story
earlier was we took those stem cells we
multiply them and multiply multiply
multiply so they're just they're
dividing and doubling right so if you
remember from high school biology cells
undergo mitosis right so they just like
divide and these will divide again this
is right again so they keep doubling so
the population just just goes like this
it's exponential right so at a certain
point you have a enough in our case
enough to go to the feed people and then
we take those and we induce them to
muscle in fat so then the muscle we had
separate pork muscle and pork fat and
then we put them together and then we
make a sausage out of it so then you you
have one cell proliferation of muscle
and one of fat and then there's a
induction that happens to me well the so
the stem cells are what you proliferate
yes so when we have this like
exponential curve these are all stem
cells yes stem cells and we have like a
giant giant massive stem cells yes and
then we divide them and then we induce
this one to muscle and this one to that
Oh induce it to muscle and do see to
that how do you make one muscle how do
you chose one change so there's a growth
factors again Oh grow Oh interesting
then you had the muscle growth that
exactly and versus the fat one precisely
yep
and then once they grow for how much X
amount of time longer then you maybe mix
them like a pork sausage gets me right
exactly they put it a lining like yep so
we had a vegan casing in our case so we
worked with a chef so he has he's
actually a butcher here in San Francisco
and 20 years of experience and butchery
and making sausages yeah so he contacted
us he said like hey I'm I'm really
excited about what you're doing it's
amazing for for the future for my
children like I've been in this industry
for a long time and I see that it's
going downhill as far as quality and
sustainability and I want to be a part
of what you were doing he approached us
like it was amazing yeah right so then
we iterated on recipes and just he was
amazing
it just has just like a knack and a
field like okay more more or less of etc
right so just like trying new we have a
vegetable broth he put in there and some
really sweet spices sweet as in like
really nice spices not sweet per se
savory spices yeah so and and then we
essentially culminated that in the pork
sausage taste in which we had September
17th and that was for 40 people in a
brewery in downtown San Francisco
Wow simulation would like to come to the
next the next one you're right so we we
try to have those recordings like
milestones right so everybody's like
when is the next one next one is like
the next milestone so we on the stage
for instance we said that we've
eliminated FBS from our stem cell
culture media camp former vet B yes oh
sorry fetal bovine serum ah ha yep so
fetal bovine serum is the major
component in cell culture media for most
companies and essentially it's it's
quite frankly as bad as it sounds
you are taking placental fluid from a
cow right and so that the reason you
take it is it has a lot of growth
factors yeah and it has a lot of
nutrients and it's a really easy way to
make a cell grow now you there
there have been FBS free formulations in
human tissue engineering so a lot of our
technology is a derivative of human
tissue engineering and and it kind of
makes sense that it's what should say
that in the human tissue engineering
context for instance you'll if you have
like a heart faulty heart muscle I may
take a biopsy of it put it in a flask
grow it out and then put it back
side of you and so the Chancellor
rejection is very low right but then if
I go and spend a hundred thousand
dollars doing it and it fixed you up and
you live the next 20 years you're happy
to pay that right so there's not a whole
lot of downward pressure on the
protocols and the recipes if you will to
to improve these these cells like the
media for the cells now if we go and
take this same recipe that we're using
for human tissue and put it over here
our goals are very different we want to
make a huge amount of very low cost yeah
meat right and the difference also is in
the functionality right so if I go and
put that heart muscle inside of you I
expected it's gonna last there for 20
years right you have to have the
signaling pathways and you have to have
the nerves nerve endings and has to beat
like a heart for you know 20 years ago
alive or longer you live a long time so
a long time right
whereas in our case how long is it gonna
last you're gonna eat it it's gonna
taste good it's gonna be healthy that's
out your system a couple days right so
the what we say is the functionality is
different yes sort of making a higher
higher volume a lower cost and a lower
functionality than human tissue
engineering and then this so do all of
the clean meat companies are they all
using FBS or I don't know one that
didn't start using FBS right okay so
this is kind of a holy grail for the
industry is you'll you'll start using
that as I just say that there are FBS
reformulations in human tissue
engineering they're very expensive right
and that's again the whole different
market to the product market so in in
our FBS despite it being expensive it's
actually cheaper than a lot of custom
formulations without FBS and then we
take it out afterward that's the process
is you well there's a growth factor and
then you take it out so so the process
actually is we are making a custom
formulation without FBS we yes we've
removed it entirely and we use like
other five years you have first to learn
about the process Oh interesting
yeah oh you all got it so then it gets
completely removed from all processes
yep um yeah got it got it yeah so we're
very much in the research phase so in
the beginning the research phase just
understanding how our cells behave in
the end to kind of define our protocols
we we use those but very quickly during
like our four months of a new bio we
them from the stem cell in the fat cell
culture media and so we're two out of
three and we are removing it from the
muscle cells now so in a very short time
we'll have that we'll have an entirely
fetal bovine serum free formulation and
then what what was we we were going to
were talking about the next milestone
and that's where yes so tell us about
that next one well that will be the next
milestone
okay so FBS free I've been o'cool and
then that is from September what's the
last milestone when is this next one so
we think is it's we say a couple months
so we're and that is yeah so it should
be hopefully this your early next year
late this year whole late this year
early next year yeah I have some awesome
hospitality and food industry people
okay would that would love to help
produce a really solid event for for you
guys so let's let's explore if I'm
looking at you you guys know I'm
thinking about so okay so let's explore
that and okay so what does this so now
you have a vegan lining and you're
putting the the proliferated and
inducted mixture into the pork yep
casing into the vegan lining casing so
then from there then is there another
sort of proprietary step that you're
taking in order for it to taste its
touch all the senses I'm gonna make it
as close to yeah so yeah it's a it's a
great question and I kind of put in
context the first time I tried our
culture meat it was the week before the
tasting and we had bought some pork of
the store and grounded up interesting so
that we could kind of compare it to what
we were making right we wanted to make
sure we were making the same thing just
I was lying test it so we had this busy
kitchen right where the containers of
our meat and then the the cell culture
meet and then also the the stuff from
the store and the chef was cooking stuff
up and and so he handed me something and
I ate it and like okay it's bacon I
recognize that
so can I try stuff we made
I said that is the stuff you made so oh
I was like well that's just bacon right
so it's not that it tasted like bacon it
was bacon right I've eaten a lot of
bacon it's so cool that yeah you really
can taste the stuff we made yeah that is
that is it exactly right so and that's
kind of like put in context it was like
they you're saying like what do you add
to do next to make it taste like making
like know it it's bacon it does muscle
poor muscle and pork muscle and muscle
pork fat mix it together it's making
when this bacon is right
just like ground up bacon good work no I
love hearing that because it it's always
that quick you know it's that quick and
you you know it'll be interesting you
know those commercials from back in the
day when they were trying to be like can
you tell the difference between Coke or
Pepsi right yeah so I think it's time
for that in the clean meat era like it
could be like we are ready to make those
commercial for you so let's let's make
it let's make it happen
all right let's make those commercials
action this could be good commercials
yeah those would be hella good
commercials cuz and and then let's
release the actual transparent numbers
as well of how many people couldn't
couldn't couldn't distinguish between
the servants that they that they were
like I don't I just take tried both and
I have no idea where I thought this and
that they call it maybe they call it
right all right so let's blow that be
super fun yeah it's actually part of our
seed base like it's love it
the part of the deployment of funds is
to do that very thing yeah it's exciting
yeah okay so deployment of funds wait so
doing some of the taste testing blind
taste testing what else are you doing
with the deployment of funds right so we
have a bunch of science milestones and
then some business and product
milestones right so the science
milestones are very much around how do
we remove LPS entirely right and then
increase the cell density and then just
and then hone in on the exact protocol
that were going to be using so we have
like a bunch of protocols that that give
various benefits right kind of it's like
a saga trade-off this one's good this
this one's good this not so good at this
so we're gonna be deciding on which one
that is
also on our bio reactor or cultivator
design and then also very much on safety
we believe on we believe in obviously
keeping the public safe so right now we
have toxicologists looking at our meat
right so we want to we want to police
ourselves if you will want to make sure
that when this comes to market that
people don't have any fear this is like
no no we've tested this so we're doing
that as well no the the business side
it's very much okay the the formulation
of the product we'll say like the
business flash product side it's very
much the formulation of the product and
then who's eating it right where are
they eating it and then what do they
care about like who what do they want to
see in in this meat that we're making
because we are decoupled from an animal
think about it there's only so much that
you can re-engineer an animal in order
to make it taste different or textured
or whatever right there's only so much I
can engineer Pig to give me a different
taste in our case we control the entire
system we control everything that goes
into the cells everything that goes out
of cells in the environment right you're
about to be able to do so much more
exactly right so we can start you know
we can feed it whatever amino acids
fatty acids minerals etc to give it the
type of taste that people want so we can
actually start at humans perception of
meat why do we enjoy meat what is it
about it and we can work back when we
make our meat meat that and then exceed
that right so what are the new and
interesting taste that you that would be
amazing so right now we're actually
speaking with chefs food scientists
molecular gastronomist to say like
what's what's actually difficult for you
to do in a kitchen for instance and then
can we go and actually do that to
ourselves and then you don't have to in
the kitchen you know it's actually it
comes out that way tasting a certain way
so these are the type of things are
working on also turns even sweet so
okay so you are scaling up and can you
describe this cell density when scaling
up right so how does one handle cell
density how do you get into those big
bio reactors like how does one finally
start growing this by like the tons
mm-hmm how does one do that well yeah
there's a skillet process so right now
we're at the you know right now or the
pre seed phase so we have nd BIOS money
and essentially they give you a certain
chunk of cash and they say you have four
months go do something right and so
we've taken part of that to invest in
developing a proprietary bioreactor
which which as I said presentation has
10 times the density so you can grow ten
times the cell then the industry
standard
we think that's pretty important so then
it's a matter of okay like and this is
obviously at a smaller level but during
the seed phase then we start to scale
that up and so it's you you scale it up
by by different discrete steps right so
you you may go one liter to five liters
of 20 liters etc right so and this is
you know I'm the chemical engineer this
is kind of my background right so like
as you go up you get different forces
right you could different fluid dynamic
forces you get different heat and mass
transfer forces or heating mass transfer
we'll say and so that affects the cells
differently and so you have to go at
each discrete point and you have to test
the cells so that is that scale process
yeah wow I love all those variables you
were enlisting because it definitely
showcases the sheer complexity of
everything that's going on now what what
what is what did you put in the
bioreactor that made it so that it had
ten times cell density what are we put
in there what's still the stating it
yeah oh yeah that's patentable so we
will be filing patents on that and then
you'll be able to read about it yeah
yeah okay so okay then what what are
because you okay completely no FBS
completely no FBS
what were the other parts of the scale a
process that you're just describing what
the seed money that are that are gonna
happen the scale across ecology yep zoom
yeah okay so making sure there's no no
toxicity but well yeah what are the so
we talked about the let's see the the
decision on cell lines for instance we
also talked about the removing FBS the
cell density toxicology then the the
bioreactor design or the cultivator
design that's right here and then we we
also talked about like how to scale that
in a facility so it's not just yeah it's
not just how does the how does the
bioreactor look but then also was the
facility that makes it right so you have
to kind of design that so we're and and
that's not something we're gonna be
building at seed we will be designing
that right here so that when we move on
to series a then we and then that I
noted the brewpub experience so once we
yes yeah so there's a lot of people that
can't eat pig mmm kosher mmm peeps so
that's
they can connait eat this it's an
interesting question so it was so we
have spoken rabbis and we've kind of
like read about what what they think and
it's kind of right now it's just kind of
divided some people say yeah obviously
you can and there's like nope can so
it's a great question is it still came
from the stem cells of a pig there's
that yep and then there's the other one
which is like all the pigs not being
touched or harmed no so we can need it
right so really depends on you know how
you interpret interesting yeah
the interpretations okay so 60% of all
pork is consumed in Asia mhm
so what does this mean from the
calculations of sustainability do we
know like Oh as far as is our better
than yeah yeah oh yeah yeah so you know
University of Oxford released a study
recently there been a bunch of studies
on lifecycle analyses so for instance I
think the latest numbers would be we
will be using 99% less land will be
using 96 percent less water
ninety-five percent less greenhouse
gases and on the energy side that's
that's probably where it's not quite
like it's we're we're better but we're
not like ninety nine percent better
right so we'd be latest estimates be
like 65 percent better or something like
that right are you yeah so and energy
wise yeah so across the board there's no
metric where we're worse than yeah an
industrial animal agriculture yeah and
those are big numbers on land and water
and also just yet there seems to be more
and more that's pointing towards eating
stressed animals causing severe disease
within humans yep so having the
opportunity to to to have massive
bioreactors let's let's get this around
the world right let's get us around the
world and and get the taste tests around
the world yeah as quickly as possible
any last thoughts about what's going on
with New Age well I mean the thing we
like to keep bringing up is that we can
make meat that's tastier healthier and
more sustainable right so it at the end
of the day customers will vote based on
is it better is a better meat right for
me
so in that in that context it kind of
like touched on the fact that it's going
to be tastier because we can make it
tastier and they're also healthier
they're just thinking to get out of a
box right so for free when we make this
you won't be getting any Listeria e-coli
Salmonella right so right now we have
traditional meat and we kind of treat it
in the kitchen there's kind of this
toxic substance like if you put on a
cutting board you cut it you'll make
sure you wash that thing really well
before you cut anything else cuz you may
get sick think about that like that's
why is that was a lot of bacteria in
there right so you get that for free you
also on the public health side we're not
feeding eighty percent of the
antibiotics that we use to keep
ourselves alive to animals who aren't
sick which create antibiotic resistant
superbugs and 23,000 Americans die every
year from antibiotic resistant
infections right yeah it's a lot two
million people get sick two of Americans
get sick right that's just America
feeding the animals antibiotics then
we're eating the animals exactly yeah
and then the animals themselves like I
would like to say that if our
if I were supervillain creating it
wondering create a superbug I couldn't
do better than industrial animal
agriculture yeah right like it's you
literally put all the same type of
animal together in a very cramped and
dirty environment and you give them most
of them are still healthy and you and
you give them antibiotics and that
creates antibodies resistant superbugs
and then you put them in contact with
humans so it can transistor transfer
humans
it's a terrible it's it's it's a system
designed to to create these superbugs
and we see that we see over and over
again like antibiotics of last resort
there are unfortunately big farms in the
US and China that are feeding these
antibiotics last resort the ones that
keep us alive when I say that the last
resort they're the ones that keep us
alive to pigs in order to make them
fatter in order to in because they're in
dangerous conditions and as a result now
there are antibiotic resistant
infections that kill people they come to
the hospital and no antibiotics for work
on them and they die so we're gonna fix
that so that's a heavy no that's a
that's a heavy okay maybe we then but
that's a very important
maybe we just briefly on the way I'll
just talk about the first strategic
steps to getting it into grocery outlets
nationwide and worldwide how does that
after or does it directly sell through
New Age meats calm you know like and do
it's nice yeah yeah skip the website so
we were possible yeah
our first will be in restaurants
so we foodservice restaurants and that
is because as I said earlier our
technology is right now a derivative of
human tissue engineering and is
expensive so we are the whole you know
my whole presentation earlier was ways
to drop the cost and certainly dropping
the cost and so the first we're gonna be
we're gonna week follow what we call the
impossible model right impossible foods
model yeah so impossible there's a
really really good job at first going
they had a higher end product and they
went into restaurants first and as they
reach economies of scale they're able to
drop the price down and then they move
into like White Castle now right so oh
they did they did right
you seem horrified and delighted at the
same time I feel I feel incredible that
White Castle adopted it and I also feel
incredible that how could they have
possibly gone the price down so yeah
that's insane and so we don't just talk
about we're gonna do
impossible model well we actually are
one of our visors was employee number
eight and impossible foods and then one
of our other contractors like did the
rollout and impossible in certain
markets right so we're like okay we were
gonna we're not just giving lip service
to the idea like we're actually we have
the right people on board to do oh yeah
because I believe impossible started
with like a twenty dollar burger at the
and then now it's a White Castle level
yeah so that seems to be a similar model
so and then and so then eventually a
rollout would be through like a national
like chains yeah yeah yeah but but it's
also grocery is that another definitely
and that's down the road because we won
we want to be branded we're gonna make
our own branded products and the reason
is is because these are different
they're they're from cell culture and
they have all those benefits that I said
right so they're better for the
environment they're better for your
health they're better for animals and so
we want customers to be able to choose
that we want them be able to see that so
we won't want to make a commodity
product because a commodity product will
just be the same as what already exists
right ninety-five percent of pigs for
instance are factory farmed so from and
then 99.9 percent of chickens are
factory farmed right so if we're making
this cell culture media with all these
better you know all these benefits then
we want you to be able to choose that so
we brand them in the restaurants and
then when we move to grocery stores
they'll be branded there as well people
be able to choose that yes choose for
their health choose for their family
choose choose for the animals choose for
they planet and it's tastier yeah yeah
awesome I was just thinking about some
really funny branding things I don't
know like happy pigs or something on
your on your brand like New Age meats
with like happy yes or something like
for Alex because or something
something interesting like that Bryan
what a freaking pleasure this is big
thank you so much for coming I've
enjoyed it thanks for having us about
your building and cool huge
congratulations thanks very much
yeah thank you it's been cool
[Music]